discussion d'experts autour de la
joconde avec cette question qui divise
les spécialistes faut-il ou non
toiletter un chef-d'oeuvre au risque de
dénaturer le tableau le conservateur du
louvre a tranché pas question que la
joconde retrouve ses couleurs d'origine
gérard dalmaz jean louis goût c'est
d'abord on ne la voit pas et puis on la
devine la star du louvre est forcément
par la vue la foule qui se bousculent
dans le coin depuis quinze 103 le
sourire de mona lisa est toujours aussi
énigmatique mais le tas a jauni alors
espèrent certains spécialistes pourquoi
ne pas lui refaire une beauté
retrouvant les couleurs magiques de
léonard de vinci alchimiste des pigments
aussitôt dit aussitôt fait à turin grâce
au lifting de l'ordinateur virtuel
cette peau de jeune fille serait
peut-être possible en allégeant les
nombreuses couches de vernis devenu
jaune par oxydation le louvre n'est pas
emballé par cette idée d'intervention
s'attaquait la joconde le chef-d'oeuvre
une aventure qui peut tourner au
vinaigre on ne commence une restauration
que lorsqu'on sait où on va précisément
lorsque l'on sait
la pellicule de vernis jusque jusqu'où
elle peut être enlevée que l'on connaît
parfaitement les pigments et rapidement
attisées par le peintre bref lorsque
l'on connaît bien à l'artiste on peut se
lancer dans une restauration n'ont pas
sans souci mais en tout cas en étant
dans de bonnes conditions
dans qu'anodin de vinci comme je vous
disais en fait à l'heure actuelle nous
sommes relativement pauvre en
informations sur cette équipe
dans la galerie proches les grands de la
croix sont aussi embrumé de jonathan
mais les conservateurs du louvre préfère
ne pas y toucher
en 1990 les gigantesques noces de cana
voisine du mythe romantique ont été
heureusement restaurer mais les
spécialistes ont eu la surprise pas
vraiment bonne de découvrir des ajouts
et la véritable couleur verte de ce
personnage de véronèse alors méfiance
qu'est-ce qui peut se cacher dans la
carnation et les paysages de la joconde
le louvre répond pour l'instant dans le
doute abstiens toi